[Musik]
Corona nachgehakt in Corona nachgehakt
spreche ich jetzt mit Professor Hendrik
Streeck und ich spreche über etwas was
uns alles ein bisschen Angst macht
nämlich Omicron Omicron die neue
Variante die Mutation
ist die wirklich so gefährlich wie
manche sagen müssen wir da eine große
Sorge haben eigentlich können wir ja
dann noch gar nicht soviel zu sagen weil
die omnicon Variante kennen wir bisher
nur vom Genom also sie wurde
sequenzierte und dadurch natürlich
hinweg das ist eine komplett neue
Variante ist aber wir können zwar vom
genomen so ein bisschen ablesen was so
ne neue Variante bedeutet und wir können
auch als Biologe da so ein paar
Rückschlüsse ziehen aber wir können
nicht vorhersagen die sie in seiner
Gesamtheit so ein Virus sich dann
verhält ob es besser übertragbar ist ob
die Impfstoffe schlechter wirken das
müssen wir dann erst noch im Labor
testen und dazu muss dass wir erstmal an
gezüchtet werden also isoliert werden
und dann im Labor z.b. mit Blutproben
von geimpften Menschen zusammengebracht
werden um zu schauen wie das Verhalten
Verhalten des Virus wirklich ist haben
sie erwartet dass so etwas wie oft also
das besondere an omnicon ist ja es hat
80 über 80 unterschiedliche Mutation im
genomen viele davon sind bekannt aus
anderen Varianten also wir sehen z.b.
aus der Alpha und Delta Varianten
Variante Kombinationen da drinnen die
wir vorher schon mal gesehen haben was
ist besonders macht das so viele auf
einmal auftreten und 32 Mutationen im
Oberflächenprotein vorkommen also am
Spike Protein und das ist natürlich das
Protein wo das
die Impfstoffe und die Immunantworten am
Ende ansetzen dass so viele Mutationen
über die Zeit passieren damit würde man
schon rechnen dass es eben eine
natürliche Evolution des Virus und das
Besondere an dieser Variante ist dass es
wohl in einem Patienten sich über sehr
lange Zeit entwickelt hat und man nimmt
an dass das in einem HIV Patienten
gewesen ist wo das Immunsystem einfach
nicht richtig das Virus bekämpfen konnte
und dann über einen sehr langen verlauft
das Virus 1 Jahr sich weiterentwickeln
konnte ich Texte sind Spezialist Experte
für HIV sich schon sehr lange schon
daran war das abzusehen dass es
möglicherweise eine Variante gibt die
aber an solchen Patienten auftauen also
ist es anzunehmen dass solche Varianten
sich präferentiell in
Personen mehr oder Patienten bilden wo
das Immunsystem nicht so gut
funktioniert mehr also auch in Patienten
z.b. die
Krebserkrankung haben onkologisch
behandelt werden da sie in dir häufiger
so längere Verlaufe von
Coronavirus Erkrankungen und wo das
Virus auch sich sehr viel schneller
weiterentwickelt das ist jetzt ein HIV
Patient war das ist natürlich
naheliegend aber es war jetzt nicht
speziell dass ich Gerät damit gerechnet
habe das ist ein HIV Patient sein müsste
ein Virus der sich verändert in einem
Patienten und man entdeckt ihn gar nicht
wie kommt er denn dann sozusagen in eine
südafrikanische Variante wie wir jetzt
festgestellt haben wo möglicherweise
Südafrika auch gar nicht der
Ausgangspunkt war also man muss sich das
so vorstellen dass ich ein Patient mit
dem NTV infiziert waren mit Corona
infiziert hat und über Wochen mit dem
Virus infiziert war aber kein sich das
selber nicht eradizieren konnte selber
nicht geheilt werden sich selber nicht
ein Konto vom Virus vielleicht wurde er
auch behandelt man hat versucht
vielleicht auch mit Antikörpern dagegen
vorzugehen und es hat nicht gut die
Behandlung hat nicht gut angeschlagen
und so konnte sich das Virus über Wochen
und vielleicht sogar Monate
weiterentwickeln wir wissen ja nicht wie
lange diese Entwicklung war hier in
Deutschland beobachten wir auch solche
Entwicklungsschritte in Patienten die
EZB onkologisch behandelt sind die kein
gutes Immunsystem haben da können wir
schon auch über Wochen in einigen
Patienten sehen wie sich so ein Virus
auf weiterentwickelt das ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt
überraschend wie das jetzt aber in dem
speziellen Fall bei Omicron gelaufen ist
das kann ich natürlich nicht sagen es
wird ja immer wieder auch gesagt von den
Gegnern des impfen wenn Menschen geimpft
sind können sich solche Mutationen
schneller und er entwickeln ist das so
nein das ist so gar nicht so also
mittlerweile gibt es Studien und auch
epidemiologische Studien die zeigen dass
die Länder die am schnellsten im in
Fortschritt sind für die meisten
Menschen geimpft sind desto weniger
tritt in diesen Ländern Virus Evolution
auf man kann ich jetzt noch nicht genau
ist noch nicht völlig geklärt woran es
liegt dass das nicht so schnell eine
Virus Evolution in
Ländern mit hoher Importe ist also warum
die herabgesetzt ist aber man kann sich
das vielleicht so vorstellen dass
das Virus Zeit braucht sich zu
entwickeln in der Evolution vor zu
streiten bei einem geimpften Personen
greift aber sofort auch wenn er sich
infizieren sollte greift sofort das
Immunsystem hat und man setzt dem Virus
überhaupt keine Zeit sich zu entwickeln
und darum sieht man wahrscheinlich auch
weniger in der Evolution oder weniger
Veränderungen bei geimpften Menschen als
bei ungeimpften
Oberflächenprotein haben wodurch
vielleicht einige infant Worten also
einige der Immunantworten wegfallen
können aber viel wichtiger ist
eigentlich im Stoff wird gar nicht mehr
so stark
na ja das können wir ja nur in das
können wir ja nicht wirklich sagen ob er
weniger stark wirkt oder nicht aber man
kann mit so vielen Mutationen damit
rechnen dass der Impfstoff vielleicht
ein bisschen herabgesetzte sind seiner
Wirksamkeit wodurch kommt es aber
zustande dass wir trotzdem noch genug
Immunantworten haben ist dass er ja
nicht nur mit einem Antikörper gegen das
Virus vorgehen sondern mit einer ganzen
Armada einer ganzen Armee von
unterschiedlichen Antikörpern die das
Oberflächenprotein dass wir uns
angreifen jetzt hat man eben mögen mag
es sein dass 23 diese Antikörper
Antworten wegfallen aber man hat ja
immer noch den Rest der Antikörper die
dagegen vorgehen da ja hilft auch eine
Booster Impfung bei wenn man gegen
Corona jetzt 1 boosterimpfung nimmt dann
werden auch diese subdominant and
Antworten also die kleineren Antworten
werden auch gepostet und können dann vor
allem auch gegen Omikron wertvoll sein
werden wir in allernächster Zeit wissen
wie die Impfung z.b. gegen Omikron wird
unten gefährlich dieses Virus ist oder
müssen wir dann sehr lange Zeit her in
den Laboren abwarten wo geforscht ich
kann ja einmal kurz erklären wie solches
Wissen dann zustande kommt auf der einen
Seite
sind die Virologen und die Monologen
gefragt indem sie das Virus erstmal
isolieren anzüchten und dann in Kontakt
mit Plasma oder quasi Blut von 1 gegen 1
gegen seine Person bringen und dann
schaut man sich das in vielen
Wiederholungen an von vielen
verschiedenen Menschen wird das Plasma
genommen und geschaut wie gut das Plasma
immer noch oder das Serum immer noch das
erkennen kann das ist so die erste
Evidenz Diba relativ schnell bekommen
werden zusätzlich müssen wir
epidemiologisch abwarten und schauen wie
häufig kommt es eigentlich zu ins
Durchbrüchen
Bionicon im Vergleich zu data Variante
oder im Vergleich zu Alpha Variante das
sind so die Daten die vielleicht ein
bisschen länger dauern und dann
natürlich auch vielleicht
Beobachtungsfehler erstmal ja
ausgeräumt werden müssen damit man nicht
glaubt dass alles jetzt an Omicron liegt
sondern vielleicht auch andere Faktoren
eine Rolle spielen das dauert vielleicht
ein bisschen spät länger aber insgesamt
glaube ich schon dass er in den nächsten
Wochen sehr schnell da zur Klarheit
haben wir jetzt haben auch die
Impfstoffhersteller schon gesagt die
richten sich quasi schon darauf ein den
Impfstoff so zu verändern gerade beim
mRNA Impfstoff etwas von biontech wie
schnell geht denn so etwas und kann man
dann tat sich diese neue Variante auch
damit abwehren nun ist das erstmal gut
dass sie Impfstoff Hersteller für den
schlimmsten Fall sich vorbereiten
nämlich dass sie im Stoppwirkung
deutlich heruntergesetzt ist wie gesagt
wir wissen ja nicht wie die sehr sehr
runtergesetzt sein wird und dass sie
jetzt Hasi ein bisschen Zeit sparen die
Herstellung eines neuen Impfstoff es ist
nicht kompliziert die Anpassung erstmal
ist nicht so kompliziert und dann schon
einmal Einnähen Stoff hergestellt haben
der gegen Omikron optimal funktionieren
kann dann wird wird ja das Ergebnis sah
sein wie gut die im Stoffe noch wirken
und sie werden die Möglichkeit haben
dann entweder eine klinische Studie zu
machen den neuen und Stoff auf den Markt
zu bringen der vor allem auch gut gegen
Omikron wirkt oder die im stoppe Übung
ist immer noch gut genug und dann wird
dieser im Stoffe erstmal ja nicht
weiterentwickelt hierbei um ist mit
einem
Virus zu tun haben mit einer Mutation zu
tun haben die sehr viel schneller an
deckend ist da gibt es ja durchaus die
Befürchtung dass das so sein könnte die
muss man dann damit umgehen ja also die
Befürchtung wird ja daher das ja einige
Mutationen gesehen haben in dem Virus
was darauf schließen könnte dass die
Übertragbarkeit erhöht ist ob das jetzt
wirklich der Fall ist das müssen wir
sehen das können wir können wir wirklich
noch nicht sagen
der Umgang mit Omicron ist aber
dergleiche dann am Ende die wir jetzt
mit Delta haben also idealerweise im
Moment impfen und Boostern und
aha und L Regeln und natürlich dann
einen hohen Inzidenzen Kontakt
Beschränkungen helfen uns auch weiterhin
dieses Virus einzudämmen könntest dazu
kommen dass wir wenn es unterstellt
ansteckender wäre tatsächlich in dem
öffentlichen Bereich
stärker noch einmal reduzieren müssen
was heißt möglicherweise zu einer Art
von
lokalen lockdowns kommen müssen die
Kinder sehr spekulativ jetzt auch das
Bild an die Wand zu malen dass er jetzt
miteinander super Variante zu tun haben
wo wir eine enorme Übertragungen haben
werden natürlich muss man alle
Möglichkeiten die man hat zur Virus
Eindämmung auch in Betracht ziehen am
Ende wenn es denn so wäre dass es eine
schlimmere wirklich schlimmere Variante
ist aber im Moment wissen wir das alles
nicht und unser Hauptproblem ist wie ich
eben ja schon mal gesagt hatte ist die
Delta Variante und das vor allem in den
südlichen Bundesländern
jetzt frage ich zwar einen Biologen aber
er kann sicherlich auch sagen diese
Verbreitung um die welt die versuchen
jetzt alle Länder möglich einigermaßen
zu bremsen um einfach Zeit zu gewinnen
wie lange kann man das machen Band ist
sozusagen der Virus eigentlich überall
hin
ja also wir werden das Virus nicht
aufhalten können in der neuen Variante
also wenn es eine Variante weltweite
geben sollte die sich besser durchsetzt
als die andere Variante also wenn Sie
einen
Vorteil hat in der Verteilung zum
Erfinder Übertragung bessere Flucht
Mutation von Moon System oder eine
höhere virale Fitness wie wir das nennen
dann wird sich dieses der Virus auch
weltweit durchsetzen also sobald man
eigentlich diese Mutation entdeckt hat
irgendwo im Moment ist sie
wahrscheinlich auch schon in anderen in
anderen Länder verteilt gewesen was man
ja jetzt sehr gut auch an Omicron
gesehen hat wir wären die können die
Verbreitung nur verlangsamen wir können
sie aber nicht dauerhaft aufhalten
könnte um Nicole vielleicht um es mal
auf positivamente zu formulieren eine
Mutation sein die schon zeigt dass das
Virus vielleicht nicht mehr so
gefährlich
ja es gibt ja die ersten also die ersten
Fälle die von Omikron beschrieben wurden
und das sind ja jetzt ein paar 100g sind
eigentlich alles im Moment sehr milde
Fälle also milde Verläufe leichte
Symptome aber keine Stern Verläufe man
könnte davon natürliche Wer ist
Schussfolge rotes ist nicht so ein
gefährliches Virus Dummy mit solchen
Schlussfolgerungen wäre ich aber
vorsichtig weil wir auch wenn etwas
jetzt noch nicht aufgetreten ist können
wir nicht abschließend sagen dass es ein
milderes Virus geworden also in beide
Richtung würde ich mit den Spekulationen
im Moment stand heute vorsichtig sein
weil wir weder sagen können ob es ja
milder geworden ist noch können wir
sagen es hat eine höhere
Übertragungswahrscheinlichkeit und ja
die im Stoffe wirken schlechter da muss
man eben erst mal das wissenschaftlicher
Forscher ich muss dir aber jetzt mal
abseits der Wissenschaft fragen wie
Wissenschaftler geraten gerade jetzt
auch durch Omikron unter einen enormen
Druck ganz schnell etwas sagen zu müssen
über diese neue Mutation
haben sie insgesamt den Eindruck dass
wir uns nicht eigentlich ein bisschen
mehrmal mit Wissenschaft beschäftigen
müssen und akzeptieren müssen dass
manche Dinge einfach nicht so schnell
gehen wie wir es gerne haben wollen ja
er wird das ist leider im Moment das
Problem dass wir alle eine Antwort auf
Omikron z.b. haben wollen und wir sie
einfach nicht geben können und jeder
jeden Experten den ich dazu gehört habe
die haben sich alle gleich geäußert dass
wir nicht vorschnell lege vorschnelle
Schlüsse ziehen dürfen in alle
Richtungen
im Grunde lenkt es aber ja auch von der
Debatte ab natürlich macht so eine
Variante jetzt erstmal Sorgen aber das
ist eine Diskussion die man in der
Epidemiologie und Biologie belasten
sollte weil das Hauptproblem ist sind
die sektionssaal bei uns und darauf
müssen wir uns konzentrieren ganz egal
welche Variante das im Moment ist
kontrollieren wir Delta kontrollieren
wir dadurch auch geometron Variante ist
das hindern